[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí lo sé a casi todos nos gusta viajar
sin embargo os puedo asegurar queridos
amigos amigas que hay sitios que es
mejor conocer a través de las tarjetas
postales lugares donde fácilmente
podréis perder la cartera el móvil o
incluso la vida sin embargo sabemos que
entre vosotros hay amantes del riesgo
personas que oyen disfrutáis cruzando
los límites de lo prohibido por eso en
visual políticos hemos tomado la
licencia de elaborar nuestro particular
ranking de las ciudades más peligrosas
del mundo a la hora de hacer lo hemos
dejado al margen lugares que están bajo
los efectos de la guerra creemos que
aportaría poco hablaros de ciudades como
damasco o kabul el actual kit para eso
ya tenemos otro montón de vídeos este
ranking lo hemos elaborado por regiones
y hemos tenido en cuenta diversos
factores como homicidios atracos
corrupción incidentes de todo tipo e
incluso expectativas y sabéis que el
denominador común de estas ciudades es
la pobreza la desigualdad las drogas y
la falta de oportunidad para los joven
es un cóctel explosivo que termina por
desatar la violencia en muchos lugares
del mundo en este vídeo vamos a ver
algunos de los más importantes ninguno
en europa y no porque no hayan lugares
más o menos peligrosos podríamos
hablaros de marsella nápoles o la
albanesa tropo ya sin embargo lo de este
ranking va a otro nivel
[Música]
así que la pregunta es cuáles son las
ciudades más peligrosas del mundo en qué
lugares tendrías que andarse con mucho
ojo hasta para comprarte una cocacola
pues atentos pero un momento antes de
arrancar con este particular ranking
porque tenemos una noticia muy pero que
muy especial que daros y comunidad
agarrados a la silla la familia visual
polític crece una vez más en todos los
sentidos en apenas unos días tendremos
con nosotros un nuevo canal se llamará
visual económica un nuevo canal que nace
con el objetivo de entender mejor cómo
funciona el mundo de la economía por
ejemplo habéis oído hablar de la deuda
perpetua o qué problemas tiene el
sistema eléctrico o si se puede crear
dinero generar inflación quien pasaría
si todos los bancos quebrarán bueno pues
ya podéis suscribiros abisal económico y
dar a la campanita para estar al tanto
de nuestro primer vídeo os esperamos y
esperamos también vuestras impresiones
en momento la primera pregunta es para
todos vosotros si las camisas hawaianas
son el elemento distintivo de visual
político y los chalecos no son de
megaproyectos cuál será el look
característico de este nuevo canal
alguna idea hagan sus apuestas
os dejamos aquí el enlace y también en
la descripción
de lindo a los mares del sur
[Música]
puesto número 3 para yang gon
mianmar ese país que todo el mundo
conoce como birmania es un auténtico
polvorín en 2005 y angol dejó de ser la
capital pero sigue siendo con diferencia
la principal ciudad del país hace un año
los militares dieron un golpe de estado
otro más con el que regresaron
formalmente al poder desde entonces las
fuerzas de seguridad han aplastado
cualquier conato de protesta y la moneda
local ha perdido un tercio de su valor
asentando un duro golpe a la ya de por
sí maltrecha economía de los birmanos
así que si no eres víctima de un robo
corres el riesgo de que una pelota de
goma perdida se cruce en tu camino eso
sí bajo ningún concepto se te ocurre
decir que te gustan las redes sociales
facebook está bloqueado y el régimen
militar sigue estrechando el cerco bien
más renueva planes para frenar el uso de
internet con la prohibición de vpn
prohibir las vpn está claro que envíos
al político no podemos estar más en
contra de esto como dijo william wallace
puede que nos quiten la vida pero jamás
nos quitarán la libertad
[Música]
puesto número 2 para karachi
con cerca de 20 millones de habitantes
sobrevivir en la ciudad más poblada de
pakistán tiene mérito la tensión étnica
y sectaria se respira en la calle
karachi y se encuentra la provincia de
sindh pero muchos de sus habitantes no
son sindis sino mohajirs musulmanes
procedentes de la india a ellos se suman
los pastunes procedentes de las zonas
fronterizas con afganistán algo que ha
llenado la ciudad de integristas
islámicos aun así el principal enemigo
de todos los karachi es sigue siendo la
pobreza son frecuentes los atracos
violentos en sus interminables atascos
de tráfico atascos en ocasiones
provocados por barricadas colocadas por
las propias bandas criminales la buena
noticia es que las autoridades se están
moviendo para salir de este ranking
[Música]
el proyecto karachi ciudad segura dotado
con 150 millones de euros prevé instalar
en la ciudad alrededor de 10.000 cámaras
de video-vigilancia con tecnología de
reconocimiento facial también prevé
reemplazar en los vehículos las placas
de matrícula tradicionales por otras de
identificación por radiofrecuencia
capaces de ser detectadas por estas
mismas cámaras el problema es que
karachi ciudad segura lleva ya siete
años de retraso y acumula un sinfín de
escándalos de corrupción
y ojo porque si conseguís escapar a todo
esto vuestra salud aún correrá peligro
karachi es una de las ciudades más
contaminadas del mundo por el tráfico
rodado y la quema descontrolada de
basura el sistema de alcantarillado es
horrible no hay agua potable y abundan
los mosquitos transmisores de
enfermedades por si esto fuera poco los
servicios sanitarios son malos y caros
así que si no eres bin laden tienes poco
que hacer por estas tierras puesto
número 1 para port moresby la capital de
papúa nueva guinea es un lugar tan pobre
y peligroso que cuando en 2018 le tocó
al país ser anfitrión de la reunión
anual de la apec a la que acudieron
entre otros shipping trudeau o el
vicepresidente estadounidense pence
tuvieron que alquilar tres cruceros para
acoger a todas las delegaciones y
garantizar su seguridad en la ciudad la
tasa de desempleo es superior al 50 por
ciento con una población de 250 mil
habitantes es un lugar donde las tasas
de homicidios son excepcionalmente altas
gracias principalmente a las pandillas
rascón que controlan grandes áreas
a los visitantes de port moresby que nos
salgan de su alojamiento después de la
puesta del sol y que durante el día
imiten caminar por las calles en
prácticamente toda la ciudad los rasgos
son capaces de todo desde atracar bancos
con ametralladoras m16 hasta saltar
vehículos armados con machetes pero
esperad un momento porque este no es el
único galardón que ha recibido por
moresby fijaos port moresby la ciudad
más peligroso del mundo para ser mujer
ni más ni menos que el 41% de los
hombres encuestados en papúa nueva línea
admiten haber violado a una mujer que no
era su pareja y teniendo en cuenta las
agresiones dentro de la pareja un
estudio de human rightswatch elevada
cifra hasta el 70 por ciento y ahí no
terminan todos los problemas las
cacerías de brujas en las que las
mujeres son acusadas de hechicería
ocurren con frecuencia y acaban en su
tortura y asesinato así que podemos
quitar el interrogante port moresby es
el peor lugar del planeta para ser mujer
[Música]
memorias de áfrica
puesto número 3 para lagos con más de 15
millones de habitantes esta es la
segunda ciudad más poblada de áfrica y
el centro económico de nigeria sin
embargo la inseguridad en lagos es tan
alta que muchos niños faltan las
escuelas por temor a ser secuestrados y
no la policía no sirve de nada son pocos
mal formados y peor pagados esto deja el
camino despejado a los matones locales
los llamados voices pandillas de jóvenes
que roban en las casas y asaltan
vehículos y luego está el peligro que
suponen las okada
[Música]
la socava son mototaxis que brindan una
opción económica y rápida para escapar
de los constantes atascos el problema es
que su principal método para conseguirlo
consiste en no respetar las normas de
circulación más básicas como por ejemplo
avanzar en dirección prohibida así que
[ __ ] una vacada es una de las mejores
opciones para acabar el día en algún
hospital de lados
[Música]
además las autoridades del lago se están
planeando prohibir estos mototaxis los
que se estima hay un millón recorriendo
sus calles por la colaboración que
algunos de sus pilotos mantienen con los
área voice correspondientes lo cierto
sin embargo es que prohibirlas okada
agravaría la pobreza en lagos ya que
nigeria es el país del mundo con mayor
población joven y la mitad se encuentran
sin trabajo y en condiciones muy
precarias
pues todos para casa la capital de la
república democrática del congo una vez
tan hermosa hasta el punto de ser
conocida como king label ha cambiado
tanto que sus habitantes hoy día la
llaman kim la ugl que viene a decir
quien el basurero y por si la basura
acumulada y las alcantarillas
malolientes no fueran suficientemente
desagradables la ciudad congoleña está
traumatizada por los columnas un grupo
de jóvenes armados con machetes que
roban y matan a diestra y siniestra una
amenaza grabada en el último año por los
zombis de kinshasa
[Música]
las calles de quizás han sido invadidas
por una nueva droga barata con efectos
muy potentes hablamos del bombé una
sustancia elaborada a partir de los
depósitos de los catalizadores de los
automóviles se extrae de los coches
viejos abandonados en los desguaces y
luego se procesa como una droga de
después de tomar el bombé los columna
primero se ponen eufóricos momento lo
que cometen toda clase de delitos pero
luego estos jóvenes comienzan a moverse
cada vez más y más lentamente hasta
aparecer auténticos hombres
[Música]
desde el 2020 se ha producido un nuevo
aumento de la actividad columna en
kinshasa lo que ha dado lugar a un
aumento de los delitos graves incluidos
los robos a mano armada y las agresiones
violentas por supuesto una vez más la
pobreza es la causa de tanto crimen una
gran parte de los 15 millones de
personas que se estima que viven en
kinshasa no tienen trabajo fijo ni
ingresos regulares de ningún tipo
puesto número uno para la ciudad del
cabo
sudáfrica redujo sus niveles de
violencia desde que adoptó la democracia
en 1994 pero las cosas cambiaron en la
última década el crimen violento se ha
disparado por una mezcla peligrosa de
pobreza armas y una policía que deja
bastante que desear puede que te
sorprenda pero estaba ocurrido
particularmente en una ciudad tan
turística y conocida como ciudad del
cabo- un lugar donde los homicidios se
han disparado un 60% los territorios
dominados por las pandillas son los que
hay flatts los barrios marginales para
la población negra en tiempos del
apartheid
[Música]
allí mandan bandas como the americans
the numbers band o los boys y así hasta
las aproximadamente 130 pandillas a las
que se estima que pertenecen a alrededor
de 100.000 personas en los flats en
estos barrios son frecuentes las
batallas por el territorio entre bandas
lo que provoca olas de violencia que
aterrorizan a ciudad del cabo y de donde
salen todas las armas que circulan por
los blogs pues atentos porque salen del
sitio más insospechados ex policía
condenado a 18 años por robar y revender
armas a mafiosos del cabo en total los
investigadores relacionaron más de 1.000
asesinatos y unos 1.500 intentos de
asesinato sólo con estas armas y lo peor
es que no es un caso aislado los
policías corruptos manipulan los
expedientes judiciales de los
pandilleros arrestados la taza de
condena por asesinato en los flats
apenas alcanza el 2% por tanto ante tal
impunidad no debe extrañarnos que las
bandas callejeras sigan dominando zonas
que ahora reciben nombres tan
significativos como cowboys town
y la jungla si puedes visitar la ciudad
del cabo y pasártelo pipa pero más allá
de los hoteles de lujo y las zonas caras
esta es la otra realidad que se está
imponiendo en la ciudad
[Música]
la tierra sin oportunidades
puesto 3 para san pedro sula con todo
américa latina sigue siendo la región
más violenta del mundo los conflictos
entre pandillas la corrupción y la
debilidad institucional contribuyen a
los altos niveles de violencia en toda
la región durante años san pedro sula
lució el indeseable título de ser la
ciudad con más asesinatos del mundo este
lugar se convirtió en un punto obligado
de paso del 80% de la cocaína que
circulaba desde colombia con destino a
eeuu estamos hablando de territorio
controlado por las maras la mara
salvatrucha instaló cámaras en barrios
de san pedro sula para controlar a la
población y a la policía la falta de
oportunidades sigue propiciando que los
jóvenes algunos incluso de apenas 12
años sean reclutados por estas maras
desde hace años el país ha intentado
limpiar de corrupción a sus fuerzas de
seguridad y ha conseguido reducir los
niveles de violencia pero aún no se
puede bajar la guardia en lugares como
san pedro sula donde la extorsión y los
secuestros sigue estando a la orden del
día
puesto número 2 para san luís
esta es otra ciudad que sorprende en
este ranking ya la cual en visual
político ya le hemos dedicado un vídeo
completo de mayoría afroamericana
sanluis una ciudad de 300 mil habitantes
en el estado de misurí sufre la tasa de
violencia más elevada de todo eeuu en
ella los tiroteos son frecuentes y
suelen darse en los suburbios ubicados
en el norte de la ciudad las pandillas
no son especialmente un problema en san
luis pero sí lo son el tráfico de drogas
y la violencia armada en 2020 esta
ciudad batió su macabro récord 262
asesinatos en tan solo un año de todos
los homicidios apenas se resuelve un
tercio por la falta de efectivos de las
fuerzas policiales
puesto número uno para caracas la
capital de venezuela atraviesa una ola
de violencia sin precedentes y sus 5
millones de habitantes sufren un
deterioro constante de los servicios
públicos debido a la mala administración
el régimen chavista menos de una quinta
parte de los venezolanos se sienten
seguros caminando por la calle durante
la noche y la policía tiene que hacer
inspecciones rutinarias para buscar
armas hasta en los autobuses urbanos que
circulan en los barrios más pobres
lugares como la cota 905 han sido
escenario de intensos tiroteos entre las
bandas criminales y las fuerzas
policiales han paralizado la vida
cotidiana en visual político ya sabemos
cómo se las gasta la dictadura de
nicolás maduró los mafiosos de caracas
también fuerzas de seguridad venezolanas
abatieron al cuqui un presunto líder de
una banda que aterrorizó caracas la mala
gestión y la hiperinflación han
empobrecido de la sociedad y ha ampliado
la brecha entre quienes tiene acceso a
dólares y los que no en esta tesitura
muchos no tienen más alternativa que
recurrir al crimen así que como podéis
imaginar los billetes verdes son muy
codiciados en caracas cuidado con
vuestra cartera pero se lo que muchos
estáis pensando ya está todo es que no
pensáis hablar de méxico
vuelo mexicano
lo siento mucho por todos los que nos
veis desde este fantástico país pero si
hablamos de ciudades violentas méxico
reclama su propia sección año tras año
sus ciudades lideran los rankings
mundiales de homicidios y es que el país
tiene la desgracia de estar directamente
entre los campos de coca de sudamérica y
estados unidos el mayor mercado de
narcóticos del mundo así que
supuesto número 3 para ciudad juárez
la ciudad fronteriza de ciudad juárez se
convirtió durante años en el campo de
batalla más sangriento de la guerra
contra el narco lanzada por el gobierno
mexicano una ciudad de un millón y medio
de habitantes deba sufrir más de 300
asesinatos al mes la extorsión el
secuestro y el robo de vehículos se
volvieron endémicos esto le hizo ser
reconocida como la ciudad más peligrosa
del mundo la lucha por el territorio
debilitó y fragmento de los carteles más
grandes que operaban por la zona como el
antaño todo poderoso cártel de juárez
pero ahora se está recrudeciendo de
nuevo la violencia los homicidios están
volviendo a crecer debido a que los
cárteles locales más pequeños están
actualmente luchando entre sí por su
participación en el negocio de la
metanfetamina crystal inn en el puesto
número 2 para acapulco
ojo recordad que este ranking no sólo
depende del número de homicidios amigos
amigas en los años 90 las playas de
acapulco se pusieron de moda y
alcanzaron fama mundial pero en 2007
comenzaron los problemas la violencia
estalló después de que el cartel
dominante se dividiera el trono vacante
fue rápidamente ocupado por grupos
locales más pequeños comenzó entonces
una brutal lucha por el territorio
aquello acabó con el prestigio de
acapulco como un destino idílico de
vacaciones pero un momento porque ahora
las autoridades tienen un plan infalible
para mejorar su reputación no escriban
sobre violencia por el bien del turismo
dice el alcalde sad acapulco a los
periodistas claro que si acabes a
silenciar los crímenes es la mejor forma
de acabar con los secuestros y las
extorsiones y ver a los soldados
patrullando por las playas seguro que
deja a los turistas muchísimo más
tranquilos el gran problema es que la
impunidad es prácticamente total en esta
ciudad y a falta de un cartel dominante
hay unas cuantas organizaciones
criminales dedicadas al tráfico de
heroína producida a partir de amapolas
cultivadas a lo largo del estado de
guerrero y distribuida desde allí a eeuu
y ya sabéis que donde abunda la droga
abundan los problemas
y puesto número uno para tijuana
tijuana es quitar la ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo la lucha contra el
narcotráfico ha tenido efectos
contraproducentes para la ciudad
fronteriza de la baja california la
captura de campos ha dejado a los
carteles fragmentados y luchando entre
sí y tijuana está siendo uno de sus
principales campos de batalla la tasa de
homicidios prácticamente se ha
triplicado en los últimos cinco años y
es 20 veces más alta que el promedio un
día matan a tantas personas que no dan
abasto en tijuana todos conocemos seguro
a una de sus últimas víctimas la
periodista lourdes maldonado que había
pedido ayuda y protección al mismísimo
presidente habló nosotros sólo podemos
mandar mucho ánimo a todos los que nos
veis desde todas estas ciudades por
ahora la pregunta es para ti estáis en
falta alguna ciudad en este particular
top 3 por regiones dejando vuestros
comentarios y se este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de la equis suscribiros a
visual polític si aún no lo habéis hecho
y ahora también recordad no olvidéis a
nuestro nuevo canal hermano visual y
económico un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]